the name kirk kirkorian it is vital to
modern day las vegas the light
businessman helped create the mega
resorts we see today from caesar's
palace to the mgm grand
well now his name will live on at unlv's
new medical school after a dedication
this morning
hector mejia live this afternoon with
those details hector
[Applause]
this facility will double potentially
triple incoming class sizes
producing more doctors for southern
nevada and right behind us right there
you can see cranes moving we can hear
the construction hammering and it's
incredible to watch it all unfold
when we realize the foundation was
poured just back in
january we have a first look at
renderings of the future
kirk kirkhorian school of medicine at
unlv
the 135 thousand square foot five-story
building is scheduled to open in 2022
with a larger facility classes will
increase from 60 students to 80
and eventually 120 in each class the
medical school will also have a wink for
new research and activities
the late kirk concorian was a
businessman and philanthropist in
medical
education research and other projects
not only here in the valley but also in
california
and abroad in armenia
his anonymous generosity is everywhere
but his name is nowhere
his name will be one place one place
only and never to be used again
after tomorrow's entry meeting this will
forever be known
this school as well as this building
the kirk kokorian school of medicine
at unlv
there is one more step though the name
is pending final approval from the
nevada system of higher education's
board of regents
and the project was funded primarily by
more than 150 million dollars in private
donations
and today we learned that the project
here is actually
ahead of schedule by a few weeks
reporting in downtown hector mejia
8 news now